okay welcome everybody to a very special
occasion this right here is the debut i
guess hard to say that because the
future's been out for a while of
chess.com's classroom feature but most
importantly the promise lesson during
the world chess championship that some
lucky members of our community would
have a chance to learn with fabi and
that guy that guy right below me here in
this video video recording of our
classroom tool is fabiano caruana
a man who needs no introduction but
bobby let me just say you are looking
fresh today
thanks denny so are you
oh thank you thank you well we've got a
number of uh awesome members of our
community who
qualified themselves for our contest all
they did was uh solve at least one video
lesson that fabiano did in his
preparation for the world championship a
video series that debuted a few months
ago of course you can check it out we'll
have a link to it in in the the video
notes wherever you may be watching this
whether it be on chess.com itself or
youtube or somewhere uh you can check
that out if you want uh but they they
played along and won this opportunity
and so to start things bobby has a game
he'd like to show one of his more famous
games and i'm gonna turn it over to him
don't worry bobby will do most of
talking today this won't just be a danny
show uh for those of you who are already
ready to click the mute button uh but
then we're gonna get into uh our our
questions from our members of the
community we're so excited to have
everybody here thank you so much
everybody wave because we cannot mute
everybody so everybody just wave yay all
right we're awesome here we go all right
bobby so um
we've got this game that you wanted me
to prepare and so i'm going to switch to
it now and and um everyone can see the
position before their eyes i don't
believe they can see the the move you
played um but take everybody into this
game and why you wanted to show it and
then you know it's your show man so what
what's the what's the lesson about
sure yeah so i i picked this game it was
played eight years ago in the tournament
in dortmund i was playing rusan
panamario
who was world champion
a long time ago he was
maybe even the youngest world champion
uh back in in 2002
and um i was playing with the white
pieces here
so it's clear that white has a very good
position um
and the reason why i want to show this
game i won't really say yet because it
has a bit of a surprise at the end so so
we'll leave the surprise
um but anyway when you see this position
you see that white has a very very
strong position all of white's pieces
are super active
black is not active at all
um
black is completely passive but for the
moment he's defending everything very
well
and so even when you have a very good
position you still need to find a way to
break through
uh so actually i wanted to ask you guys
um
what are your thoughts on
are on how white should play this how i
should try to improve the position and
try to make some progress here
if you think you have the answer or you
have something you'd like to say why
don't you wave in the chat so everyone
watching this can see that that might be
how coaches direct their lessons in
general using classroom uh but go ahead
and uh go ahead and let us know if you
have something and so we'll call on you
tony
tony you get to go first buddy go for it
ma'am
oh okay okay can you hear me
we can hear you man um okay so
to break the position you probably need
to go g6 at some point
okay well how well have you calculated
it what have you looked at
um after g6 i know that you know they're
not gonna take
so they're probably gonna try to trade
um maybe like a move like king v8 and uh
try to hold the position
but i think it's still very hard
after something like bishop f5
um
it's still hard for like for blacks like
so after bishop f5 because if bishop
takes then e takes f7
yeah take e takes f7 and then rook fe
for example and then ricky a and then
you win
so um i mean very hard to hold for white
and after bishop f5 like if they don't
take i mean i am blasting through okay
g6 king v8 bishop f5 what were you
saying yeah i was saying that it's very
hard to play because i mean you're kind
of stuck i'm gonna take your e6
bishop and um
i mean
i'm just of a pawn i'm gonna queen soon
so i think yeah
so this is a good thought
um
so i gave this position once before to a
group of people
and
the first suggestion that most people
came up with was bishop five immediately
the idea was this is the defensive piece
in black's position
if we remove it then we can try to
target the d5 pawn possibly the f7 pawn
the problem is that
black takes on g5
and
this kind of position like let's say
take take take it might be it might be
good it might not be
um because you're you're starting to
simplify the position enormously and you
have a past pawn but you know sometimes
these past pawns don't promote
um
so that was the first the first stop
that most people came up with and the
second suggestion was um the one that
you came up with tommy which was uh to
play g6 the pawn is potentially hanging
on g5 although not immediately because
let's say white makes a passing move if
black were to take
everything
then he would still lose a c7 pawn and
the game so
uh so it's not hanging immediately but
long term it might be a vulnerability so
it makes sense to advance it to a square
where it's invulnerable indirectly
because as you pointed out if black
captures
um the bishop hangs so this pawn is we
could say this pawn is overloaded it
wants to provide two functions one is to
stop the advance of this pawn but it has
a more important function which is
defending this piece
so
g6 is a good thought because
if we think about how black can respond
to this
there's not too many ways uh so you came
up with with this move king to b8
with the idea that you want to over
defend c7 and ask white what to do next
but this move actually has an even
bigger problem than
than bishop f5 so this is an important
theme in the position why black can't
play king b8 immediately here and also
in the future
we should we should ask everybody to
solve that what is the
what is the idea fab is referring to
that is even more powerful than the line
tony gave
throw your hand in chat kp infinite you
just waved you get to go kp infinite
what's the idea
it's just bishop a6 with checkmate
yeah that's right so bishop to a6
threatens checkmate
sorry i'm getting
you go for it go for it
um sorry i was getting error message on
my screen so queen b7 is threatened and
the only way to stop it is bishop ca but
again that bishop was overloaded and
here we can take on f7
um
this pawn is
marks the end of the game once black
loses this the rook is under attack also
this idea which tony pointed out in
another position rook t8 is coming so
everything falls apart so that's why the
king is actually stuck on a7 it can't go
to b8
um
now or in in any possible future because
bishop take6 will always be
a strong idea so for black to
try to deal with um
let's say white's pressure
uh you have to remove the queen on c6
but how do you do that
let's imagine that black were to make
um another move trying to remove this
queen
let's say blackboard play bishop to d7
attacking the queen immediately
so
does anyone have a suggestion on how the
game might develop if this were to
happen because when you play g6 you have
to also
look at some concrete variations
okay
let's see i'm going to give it one
second tony i know just because you
already went i'm i'm i'm controlling the
group session if anyone else has an idea
go ahead and wave
joma jomo bowie joe mobile how do i say
that name jama bowie jama boa you're up
dog it's jumbo and gumbo
maybe i mean i don't know but you can
take the pawn on uh d5 either with the
queen or with the
rook i would prefer the queen here
because uh now the queen isn't hanging
anymore and you want a pawn
yeah so queen d5 is correct
um this was the downside of bishop to d7
but black can eliminate that pawn on g6
now pawn takes g6 and here for the
moment it is material balance and black
is not
under a huge attack it looks like so how
does white continue here
let's see we got a lot of people waving
this is kind of cool i love this
organized cooperative fashion that
everyone is
suggesting let's go to crypto flop who
hasn't had a chance to
weigh in yet go ahead crypto
crypto we're having a hard time maybe
you could increase your volume or or
um give you one last chance then we'll
go to someone else can you increase your
volume a little bit
oops
i think i heard rook to e7
okay
which is which is actually a very
integral idea in many lines and here i
think the the point is that if queen
takes e7 queen takes g8
um
trades rooks and then g6 is potentially
hanging the problem is that we're
trading too many pieces and now black
plays g5
and we're no longer in a position where
white has so much pressure here
just because too many pieces have been
traded off so when you have a lot of
active pieces you don't really want to
to continue trading that's more the
defender's goal
so if we go back a few moves
you want me to go back or can you go
back i'll do it yeah i think i i think i
went back right okay go for it
uh so white has a stronger way here with
the idea of rookie seven
um and this one isn't very obvious
although white is winning in this
position it's not um
extremely
forcing it looks like actually tony i
see that you um
uh you're waving in chat
go ahead johnny what's your suggestion
here
i'm i'm not sure right off but what
happens after bishop before queen ca
um quintet i think is the only move
and probably rookie seven
and then if rook d8 you could probably
just take on g6 and look queen e5 and
the c7 pawn is really weak
um
i don't see another way to win this
easily
yeah that's correct so basically yeah
just take the crown queen five mcqueen's
very centralized and this is very good
for you
yeah this is correct so let's go through
it a bit uh slowly after bishop to e4
um so it threatens checkmate
and um unfortunately for black if he
tries to cover the checkmate on b7
he gets hit with another checkmate on an
unlikely square but uh but this is also
an important detail
and if blackboard plays c6 this doesn't
look
like it's immediately losing
but once the structure is
uh damaged in in this way once the
structure is kind of compromised
white just plays queen d6 rook to e7 is
coming bishop c6 is coming and the
threats are too many and we see black is
still
passive on the last two ranks doesn't
have any active ideas and will start to
slowly lose pawns or or the position
so queen to c8 if for that reason is
forced to deal with this threat now rook
to e7 comes that's why this was such an
important idea but here black can't take
it and trade rooks
so you cover the bishop with rook to d8
and now bishop takes g6 is probably a
fine move but there are even stronger
ways for example queen to f7 is a super
strong move
um and also the idea that
you mentioned to put the queen on e5
that's a perfect square
but but this one is is
possibly the strongest way white can
continue
and although white
will win the pawn and only be of one
pawn it seems like only one pawn
uh it's a completely winning position
because
uh besides upon white has all the other
positional advantages that he had before
the more active pieces black's king is
clearly the weaker one between the two
because it is
opened up while white's king is covered
by these pawns
black's king is is constantly under the
thread of this bishop on the long
diagonal
and even concretely we have threats for
example black plays g5
to
try to save the pawn suddenly white can
hit black with bishop to c6
you overload the bishop the bishop is
attacked three times now defended only
twice so it has to move and wherever it
goes including if it takes on c6 there's
rook to c7
winning the queen because of the check
so we see that white's activity although
it might not immediately come into
play long-term black won't be able to
defend old threats
um but that being said bishop g6 should
also be a very a very strong move
um
so this is why now we're starting to see
how it looks like black has many moves
here many options uh one by one that get
eliminated
and that was the way that i was um
thinking about the position before i
played g6
which was at first i thought
um
black has a ton of moves here and maybe
one of them is decent print but once i
went through them all
i didn't find any defense from here
first you see that king b8 loses to
bishop a6 so the king can't move
uh the queen can move because it has to
cover this pawn and
um let's imagine black waits with a move
like queen to c8
here white wins in a very simple fashion
uh does anyone have
or see um how white wins here
should i play queen c8 on the board or
just leave it
i think i played quinceanera right now
okay here i'll do it here locally for me
there you go
okay
i see tony's raised this hand go ahead
tony
ricky seven and the bishop tanks
yeah that's correct so gf7 bishop seven
this wouldn't be very good with the
queen on d8
um but here rook to e7 comes attacks
this attacks this and wins the game
these are either winning the queen or
the bishop
so
once you go through all those options
you start to realize that
um black is in what's called zigzwang
and it sounds very strange um
say that in the middle game because
that's a theme which is very common in
end games
and zugswong
literally translates to the pain of
having to move
and um
so
that's that's what black is in here he
doesn't want to move he would rather
wait and see what white's threat is
although white may be able to come up
with a threat like bishop to f5 as sorry
bishop
is an idea
but it's actually even worse that black
has to make a move because any move he
makes
um
damages his position
so we've gone through the king move
which loses queen moves also loose all
of them queen to ca queen to e7 all lose
in same manner which is g takes f7
uh the bishop can move because it's tied
to this pawn and so there's only one
piece left for black to move
which is the rook and this is how
my opponent played the game
but before we get into the game
continuation which was he played rook to
g7 asking me how do i want to continue
how do i want to try to make progress
here
um there's one other rook move which is
super interesting to look at which is
rook to f8
so
this time one i was actually quite proud
of uh seeing in advance how two
responses move rook to f8
so does anyone have an idea
on what to do here
i'm gonna let uh some others weigh in
and we've got tawny and kp infinite give
it a second for anyone else to also
take a moment consider the different
candidate moves
that's not just because i'm still
calculating that's not the only reason
um
as someone who knows the game i've never
seen the analysis on rook f8 so but i
think i got it too so all right let's
see we've got a few um
one wave is enough definitely we see you
we see you tawny um
and uh let's see
uh
jama bowie we'll go ahead and let you
weigh in again what are your thoughts
um
i think
can you play um
g7
and
if the rook just moves back
trying to defend um
i don't know you can't
you can't just detect the the the rook
of the bishop i see uh because the rook
just takes and uh well
oh well okay i don't think it works it's
all right
okay kp infinite you want to go we saw
you wave your hand a little earlier
yeah i was actually thinking somewhere
in the vein of uh okay so g7
then
uh
you know can i can i draw can you guys
see an arrow in here
yeah bobby i'll be able to move the
reset g7 rook to g8 uh but now just uh
you can actually sack the rook with rook
to g5
with the idea if the queen leaves the
defense with uh queen takes g5 you can
play queen to uh
queen takes c7
and uh
you're breaking through
yeah this is brilliant um this is
exactly right
and
um
i think this is a super difficult uh
thing to see an event so um so kudos
it's um
it's a really unusual tactic
because usually
um
you know you don't just leave rooks
hanging like this
and
it's very rare that
a king like this which
um
you know still has pieces which can
defend it is completely helpless
so after king day 8 white has one final
blow which is important the bishop
enters the attack bishop to b5
and bishop to c6 comes and that's
checkmate there's no way to cover that
square
uh so it doesn't matter that black's up
rook
uh his people simply can't get back in
time and it's super important that uh
we played bishop to b5 and not bishop to
a6 because of bishop to a6
uh black has the defense of bishop to c8
well bishop ca uh probably still loses
to bishop take c8 but there is the move
rook to b8
and uh and now it gets a bit tricky
um it's still good because you can you
can revert to the same idea
uh but yeah it's it's a bit trickier
than going here immediately so yeah it's
uh it's important to be accurate till
the very end because if you get here and
then you
you don't want to go for this bishop b5
idea because you don't want to go
backwards then uh you're not going to
break through
so so yeah that's correct and
uh but why is rook 25 so strong
because
yeah black can't take it but
it doesn't look like that's the end of
the game but in fact it is and um
the one reason is that after king to b8
it's still the same tactic bishop to a6
uh forces bishop tc8 to cover checkmate
and things fall apart you take here you
take here and you end up material
with the past g7 pawn so everything
falls apart for black
and if black makes a passing move let's
say he plays queen to e7
and says what are you going to do next
um here white simply retreats the rook
you can retrieve it to any square but
usually the rule is you retreat as far
away as you can
um
away from black pieces and potential
attacks
and now the thread is bishop to h7
uh so i think um
this idea was mentioned
in this position bishop h7 but here the
pawn
uh the pawn was hanging right
so
slowly right away
sorry what's up
which position were you saying bishop h7
was mentioned after rook g1 here or
i think here um
uh i think someone mentioned bishop to
h7 here as like a two move idea
um but that rook takes g7 is the problem
and so that's that's what white is
trying to build up with route to g5 it's
not just about the tactic of black can't
take because queen c7 but also because
slowly white will try to win this rook
on g8 so for example queen 7 rooks g1
bishop h7 will win that rook if black
allows it and if black tries to you know
cover it let's say f5
then suddenly we see a switch to e1
and the e6 bishop pulls
so there's uh there's a lot of tactics
um not all of them have to be seen in
advance when you play move like g6
because
you know you play g6 and you don't need
to necessarily see rook f8 because you
can kind of intuitively intuitively feel
that white probably has something here
uh because rook to f8 is a slightly
unnatural move you know it's allowing g7
with tempo
but once you get here if your opponent
plays a tenacious defense like rook's f8
then you need to start calculating all
the possible variations and and then you
find g7 rook g5 and all this stuff that
we looked at
so we're going through all blacks moves
we call them candidate moves because um
uh these are all
logical moves that both sides have to
consider
and the final move the final candidate
move which my opponent played in the
game
is rook to g7
he's also trying to to wait and see what
i do if g takes f7
then bishop takes f7 and y doesn't
really have a way to make progress
because rook
uh
sorry i shouldn't say that it looks like
white doesn't have a way to make
progress because rook to e7 uh we saw
that in this variation where the queen
doesn't cover it
rook to e7 would lose the rook
so after rook to g7
uh does anyone have ideas on
on
how to continue here
okay we've got
tawny and jama bowie
raising their hands
we'll kind of summarize this in in a
minute because i have some questions
about how you
generally kind of evaluate positions
like this maybe an educational takeaway
for the
for the students here but all right
we've got a couple people who've got
some candidate ideas
hopefully no one went out of their way
to look up caruana versus panda mario uh
from 2014 because then you would know
the answer um
[Music]
but uh
we uh
all right tawny we'll let you we'll let
you say the next idea go for it
and then rookie seven and then i was
thinking that um yeah rookie sevens are
really nice because of queen takes e7
and then bishop a6 and i think you're
just winning
yeah that's that's absolutely cool
you know this game before but yeah
measurement section i think yeah they're
it's just me can take queen eight and
couldn't be set as a software stuff
yeah that's that's correct and um and
then
also if king b8 which is the other move
can be it because the
if your opponent knows it then yeah can
be it now just bishop a6 and yeah your
opponent resigns anyway so yeah it's the
same idea so this is
a clearance sacrifice
but it's kind of unusual because the
target
which is very
it looks like it's super well covered is
a the eighth square and right now
black's two pieces are defending that
square
um so first we distract one of them
uh with this move which looks like a
blunder of the rook
um of course black has to deal with this
threat of uh rook takes c7 and king b8
doesn't cut it because of bishop to a6
as you mentioned and if queen e7
it looks like well we just we just lost
rook in the game
but bishop to a6 comes threatening mate
very unusually black has no piece to
cover that if the queen were on
you know some other square it could go
to a8 or da or b8 um but here there's no
piece to cover black has to capture the
bishop and the final the final move
queen to a8
checkmate
uh a very unusual checkmate you you
rarely see this and also
helped by the fact that the pawn on a4
covers b5
and here
[Music]
let you play it out to checkmate in the
game
yeah he was uh he was being very uh
very nice and uh he allowed the
checkmate
not not every day that uh super
grandmaster but it really is like
picturesque here right beautiful to see
all the black's pieces on the seventh
rank of a brook and bishop so i have a
question how
how early did you see this idea
in your head like whether it's you know
obviously we can go as far back as where
the combination sort of begins with g6
but certainly i'm you probably weren't
calculating that it was going to end
that way but how early were you aware of
this sort of whatever you want to call
it right attraction sacrifice and the
mating net that could have occurred here
yeah when i played g6 i i had plenty of
time so i was able to calculate all
black's
possible moves here and um and so yeah
all of it was seen up to the end
um
you you don't really need to to you know
you can also play this move on intuition
because you sort of feel that this is
the correct move and i think you guys
also suggested this move and felt that
this is the correct way to proceed you
don't need to calculate rook g7 rook
effect all these possible moves but um
if you have the luxury of time if you
have a lot of time on the clock then
uh it doesn't hurt to
uh to go as deeply as you can and to
foresee all of your opponent's possible
defenses
and if we go back just one more before
that um
when i played queen to c6
i had in mind g6 because it looked very
strong but i didn't have anything in
mind besides g6 it just queen c6 felt
like the right move
um to attack this pawn to attack this
pawn and i was actually more expecting
bishop to b7
rather than the move bishop to e6
um although in both cases black has
an incredibly
bad position bishop to b7 queen's f6
uh white keeps just a solid grip on the
position so you don't have to see
everything in advance
um
but once you get to like we could call
this a critical moment
like virtual g7 or rook to f8
whichever move black makes
it's a critical moment for white because
here is where you have a choice black
doesn't really have much freedom white
is the one who has to find a way to
break through
and um
and so here is where you have to invest
your time and energy into finding the
finish um
if white doesn't have this
and rookie 7 and this tactic which
worked in the game
uh then you have to find another way to
break through so so you kind of
let's say with experience you get a
feeling for where these critical moments
are where you need to really invest your
time and energy
i think that's instructive i think
obviously you said that the group
had a feeling that g6 was the move but
the balance between needing to go all
the way to the end versus into it
intuitively knowing that something is
the right approach i think comes with
experience but
trying to get you to elaborate a little
bit on that but it it feels like you
said like you didn't you didn't have it
all the way calculated out but once the
critical moment was hero to richie seven
what would you say develops the sense of
a player to know that like it's now or
never right this is the critical moment
you either cash in or you're going to
let your opponent off the hook what
would you what would you kind of say
about that here
oh well i read this in a book once which
is
um that there are like certain let's say
things which happen in the game which
should give you some sensitivity
and and the author listed a bunch of
different things
um
and those are like positional factors
like here we would say that
um the fact that black is very passive
that he
we made an active move and he just
starts to wait
and that he has a lot of
um
a lot of weaknesses c7 is a weakness f7
is obviously weakness because we can
capture at any time
um d5 is a weakness his king is
obviously vulnerable because we saw in
many lines bishop a6 uh coming with
amazing attack and his work on g7 is
super awkward and all these factors
combined and you you know you look at
this and you think there just should be
something yeah um
and that that then when you get that
feeling that there should be something
here
uh and i can't say that you know the
feeling will always guide you like
sometimes you feel like there has to be
something and
chess is is a tough game sometimes
there's just nothing at all
um but very often your intuition guides
you in the sense that you feel like
everything's hanging he's totally
passive i just have to have a way to win
this game and then that feeling guides
you to
uh to start to invest in calculation
um
but the factors
that um
like i don't know if you can really
let's say have a playbook of everything
that you need to to know when when you
feel that like i can say
it's because white is more active and
black has weaknesses
um
but
that's i don't know if
that will always be the case right
because chess is a very very concrete
game and sometimes
um
sometimes it's just all concrete
variations it doesn't the positional
factors don't matter but still we we see
these things
um and
and we help them
you know
let's say
like when a computer thinks about a
position it just calculates every move
but we don't have that computing power
we can't calculate every move so we have
to
use our intuition to guide us on where
to look and when to look
and and that's something what's which is
developed a lot by experience it's also
um
something where yeah you can have some
guidelines like uh you know we have a
past pawn
and we have active pieces and these
things tell us this is
my moment to strike
yeah
but yeah i would say a lot of it is
really just
um experience and intuition
awesome stuff man there you have it
right maybe you knew of caruana upon a
mario from before but never never broken
down
by by fabi fresh fabi on the mic so
that's awesome stuff and i i think i
could continue to make this a selfish
conversation and ask you more questions
about high-level processes there in
terms of your critical thinking but
we're going to turn over the floor now
everybody here
got a promise which is they're going to
get at least one question for you fabian
so
tony i'm going to do you the favor and
let you go first because of your message
about your school i don't know how you
didn't clear your schedule for this
lesson that's a you problem buddy but i
am going to let you go first no i don't
i don't want to go first
well
you might miss your question um
so then i won't make you go first but if
you don't have a question before it's
time to go then i then i can't help you
out there so i'm gonna i'm gonna turn
report guys let's see
daniel daniel lona mr lona underscore
chess
we see there do you uh have a question
prepared for for mr carwana
uh yes i do i don't know if there's any
board setups for this necessarily but i
will do my best to set up a board
magically as quickly as possible
uh yeah my my question is just simply uh
about taking advantage of the initiative
when you have it if you have any tips on
how to uh how to effectively do that
sometimes i can tell i have the
initiative but i'm not always
uh capitalizing it in the way
capitalizing on it the way i think i
should be able to uh so i don't know if
you have any uh broad suggestions for
that
thank you yeah that's a great question
and that's that's really difficult to
um to give just one piece of advice on
but when you have that feeling um that
you know you're the one who's directing
the game that you're the one who has
initiative um i i think it's very good
to trust that feeling because
sometimes feelings um you know
misguide us and it happens to everyone i
think it also happens to me that i feel
like i'm the one who's directing the
game but in fact i was never better
and um i can even
give some examples of that
but i think it it happens to everyone
all the time but generally speaking i
always advise that you trust your
intuition on that
and if you feel like you have the
initiative
um then i think it's
it's always better to go forward rather
than to go backwards like if you have
let's say a general strategy of being as
active and aggressive as possible
uh i think that will serve you better
than
you know trying not to spoil your
position or
um you know trying to play too
cautiously
uh
i can't say that's broad advice because
of course every position every game will
be different
but
as like a general piece of advice i
would say
that when you feel that you have an
initiative that trying to put pressure
on your opponent um and trying to take
advantage of what you what you think is
an advantage
that you should use that because also
chess is a game between two people
uh
so your opponent also has doubts
and if they feel like they're under
pressure
um if
if they're psychologically a bit
vulnerable because they don't like their
position then that's something you
should also take advantage of and that
would will probably serve you in
uh in most of your games although of
course this advice might you know
sometimes lead you to overextend and to
uh to lose a game because you you went a
bit wild but that happens to everyone
you know and i would i would add too
that it is something
bobby i'm sure you would agree that that
you should unpack because at different
stages of your career you might have
different struggles for example if abby
mentioned that sometimes you think
you're better and then you actually dive
into it and find out actually i was
never better and i was convinced the
whole time that i was pressing right but
maybe so that reveals certain things
like this
maybe you're miss evaluating certain
things maybe you're underestimating your
opponent's chances on a regular basis
maybe you need to improve your
positional understanding so that these
things that you think you're better at
maybe you're not and then at other times
if you're actually losing your
opportunity to convert initiative and
you're and that is proven right like the
evaluation afterwards of the engine
agrees with you that can be over a
consistent thing like are you playing
too fast in those moments right are you
not appreciating resources your
opponents have at the end of lines we
have those queue essence errors right
where you're stopping a move short i'm
obviously adding some because i also
coaching and teaching so i apologize
this is learn with bobby but i think
it's really important fabi that people
dive into this right because
because there are there are mistakes we
make in games and then there are
mistakes we're making on more macro
levels in our chess games and all of
them right and the point the reason you
should dive into it is because if you
really find a consistent pattern that
you're missing chances to convert on an
advantage there's probably a pattern
within that pattern which it could be a
number of things like i said playing too
fast not not going deep enough in your
calculations so you're consistently
missing that last resource of your
opponent etc right fabi there can be
patterns there that you start to
understand and therefore you can improve
your games on more macro levels right
yeah no i actually wanted to um because
i was just thinking about this and i
wanted to
elaborate a bit because
everyone mis-evaluates positions uh it
can be
all of us in this chat it can be magnets
it could be any world champion history
has positions that they play worse than
others where they will make
mistakes fundamental mistakes where they
just don't understand the position that
happens to everyone i can point to
recent examples like in the candidates i
lost to anish giri
i thought i was pressing i thought i was
better i was playing actively
like you mentioned i thought i had the
initiative
but it turns out i didn't i was
i was not better at all it was equal and
that feeling that i was better led me to
overpress
right and i lost that game so um
i think the thing is that we talk about
chess experience but we also need to
um
we need to separate
general chess experience from
um
well there's different types of
positions in chess so you can
um
you can say you're an experienced chess
player but that doesn't mean that you
uh know all positions equally well and
if you're trying to let's say maximize
your results it might be helpful to try
to steer the game in directions where
you know the positions better
uh and i think people at the top try to
do that they try to make sure they don't
get into unfamiliar situations where
things might go out of control because
they don't understand the position so
well but i think that's also something
that can be used at any level where if
you play
opening systems where you have a lot of
you've got garner a lot of experience
and you learn to play the positions well
um you will
be at a higher level than maybe your
general level is you might be let's say
uh
2200 as an overall level but in this
type of position you're 2400 because you
know the ideas you know the themes and
you're comfortable and you know what to
look out for and things like that so
there are things that every player can
do
in terms of trying to control the game
and steer the game in ways that
um
[Music]
that they know you know exactly how to
approach a position and don't get caught
off guard and things like that uh so
so yeah that's a bit broader than like
the initial question is but
uh there's a lot of stuff to think about
of course
every chess player has to do that
personally to try to improve you always
have to continue thinking about
uh you know what am i doing wrong where
am i making my mistakes and how can i
improve on that
awesome stuff i'll hold back adding even
more because i love this stuff it's just
psychology chess is psychology as uh
gregory cardone would say but all right
thank you for the question daniel that
was awesome who's who wants to go next
can i ask my question next go ahead tony
go for it
how do you think of the grand master
like is there something specific that
makes you grandmaster is there like
something you have to do
um well it's yeah that's a good question
it's it's difficult to say because
everyone reaches um
let's say
their
chess progress in a different different
way
and um you know everyone becomes
grandmaster in a different way and
everyone becomes
international master of 2700 or whatever
level it is uh in a different way so
um
i i don't think that there's like one
you know one formula for becoming grand
master
um
there's not like a riddle you have to
solve or something there's not like a
magic stone you have to find i've been
looking for it my whole life now go
ahead
no it's just um yeah i think everyone
will have a different answer to this
question
um but if i had to give advice on how to
reach grandmaster it would be the same
advice that i'd give on you know how to
reach 2000 if you're an 1800 player or
how to reach
um feed a master if you're a 2000 player
um which is that
which is kind of similar to what we were
just talking about
um is that
you have to try to identify your
mistakes because everyone has weaknesses
and you have to try to work on those
things
um so it's it's very much an internal
process it's not just
you know i'll work on these to study
these tactics and these openings and
improve because
most people if not all people at some
point hit
a plateau or they hit that wall where
they they're struggling to make progress
um
and very often i think that the the
reason people don't you know aren't able
to to make that
next step or they they reach a certain
level and they just stay there is um
because
you know it's uncomfortable to
uh
admit that we we have weaknesses in our
play and we have to deal with them
um
[Music]
and if you can
if you can find a way to correct those
mistakes whatever level you're at that
will
um
that'll be your surest way to
improvement
good stuff
well um we're gonna continue here and uh
remind everybody that uh
if anything chess specific happens i'll
try to ring up on the board but i think
it's probably expected a lot of the
questions might be based on your general
improvement and and things like that so
this is this is great and we'll keep
rolling along um
the uh
who who is who is next let's see drama
bowie you ready you ready to go ma'am
actually yes
um all right so first of all thanks for
the opportunity um and uh the question i
have is
how does someone
at your level or at any level how should
they uh study lines like for example i
tried to uh to study um some lines in
the tatakawa and the karakan today and
um
it's like really hard for me uh that
to
differentiate between these different
variations so how do you just repeat
lines thousands and thousands of times
or do you just
um
have a miracle way or something to
memorize them
so just to elaborate um you're
struggling with the memorization aspect
of
of openings yeah
differentiating between um this line and
that line where maybe uh
a bishop was on
somewhere
and then the other line it isn't and uh
where the difference is between um
uh
maybe here i should play the move or
here i shouldn't
yeah that's a great question um it's
it's also something that top players
struggle with i know
i'm not the only one who is struggling
with it because um
i've spoken to other players and i know
that
um one of the biggest challenges is you
analyze a lot of stuff
most people analyze on a computer
nowadays because we have really powerful
um powerful hardware and powerful
software that allows us to
to really delve deep into an opening
or to a position that we're interested
in and we do great analysis and then we
come to the board and we realize that
we don't remember half of it and we
don't understand the other half
um and that happens to everyone
uh it's it's certainly happened to me uh
so i'm still trying to find my way
in terms of how i deal with that how i
um
best memorize positions and how i best
understand them because that's another
thing a lot of times
let's say we see a computer line it
tells us this is good
and
but that could be based on crazy tactics
way down the road like just because we
see a number doesn't mean that this
number is easy or that it has any
practical
impact on on a human's game it could be
that
you know
you know that the position is uh plus
two but it's just too difficult to
figure out for for you on the board uh
so
it's not just about
um you know having good analysis it's
also about understanding the position
understanding the position that you're
looking at intimately so i think a lot
of um
that comes in over the board work so
even though
we
we have all these great tools to analyze
and to understand chess
with computers and databases and all
that stuff
um
i still think that um
over-the-board work thinking about a
position over the board
is something that
you know you you just can't replicate
that value in
in computer work uh you really need to
get down to position thinking about it
on your own not just looking at what the
computer says
and that's that's something that
everyone struggles with as well
everyone who's seriously analyzing the
openings um has a tendency to over trust
the computer
uh even though we know the computer's
right in most positions pretty much in
all positions
uh
it's still that doesn't necessarily help
you over the board
i'll just give one example because this
was
uh something i remember very vividly
about
year one half two years ago um i was
preparing for a player and i noticed he
played a certain opening in that
tournament and the player was um
was ariantari
and the line um can we like it up a
fresh board just so yeah yeah
i got you baby let's do it just tell uh
you can
can you make moves on the blank board or
i need to make you uh
yep
okay so he was playing black and he
played this in the tournament
and
um
basically this line is known to not be
very good he played it with black
against a strong player and
the game was eventually drawn but that
isn't really relevant towards opening
his opponent played d4 and they soon
reached a position
where
uh a strong computer strong stock stock
piece that we were running on on many
cores
on a cloud said plus four
um
but to
i say us uh um me and my coach at the
time uh russian cosmonaut we were
looking at it and to our eyes it just
looked like a total mess like it's at
plus four and normally that should be
the point where we say okay we're gonna
stop looking at this because the game's
over
but we looked at it and it looked
totally unclear
and so for some reason we had this idea
to run
a
uh early version of fritz um
probably some of you guys are
are familiar with the
uh the classic the um
the og chess engine fritz
i i remember when i could still be fritz
four you know what i'm talking about we
were even using we were using a fritz 13
so it was super strong by fritz
standards and we were running on like
two ports or something so
uh not 80 cores not being 100 cores or
whatever that people use these days and
brit said like
pretty much equal like 0.2
or my 0.2 it was something which was
basically saying this position is
totally unclear
and i was thinking how is that possible
that two
like quite strong computers
give one gives an evaluation what if the
game's over and the other one gives an
evaluation i don't really know what's
going on you have to look at it you have
to analyze it
and so we made them play a game
and it only became clear to fritz that
the position was winning for white
like 30 moves later
and i i was kind of shocked i was like
how is it possible it wasn't like white
is tactically winning and princeton see
it it was
that this was just winning
and it was way outside the horizon
not in a tactical sense but
just like in a positional sense almost
like in a long game
y just wins and
and we know that like this early fritz
is way stronger than
the magnus or any human player on the
planet
so
um so just by that we realize that
even though this is a winning position
and this computer shows it
um
for for a human that doesn't really mean
anything unless you actually know how to
win
you know over the board we could we
could say it's plus four white's winning
or we could say well this is
actually an unclear position and
anything could happen
um
so
i'm just using that example to
to say like
not to over trust computers because
um they've gotten a bit too strong and a
bit like they're just living in another
world now
um
so it's it's very helpful to when you're
analyzing openings
to look at it still from a human
perspective
um it's difficult uh
but looking at it over the board and
trying to think well you know
i play this and what's this black to
after what do i do after fe4 and
uh and trying to think about that and i
try to use that that tool myself when i
think about positions
let's say i'm analyzing a line and i
have all these crazy variations and i
just like to
when i'm away from the computer just
think about the position in my head and
what moves come to mind from a purely
intuitive human perspective
right
i was going to add to that i mean i
that was fascinating even for this lowly
i am and i and i to even give a little
more context
john bowie i would say that there's a
difference between
memorizing the move and then memorizing
the why and i do think obviously when
bobby tells a story about trying to you
know solve all your aryan terry's
openings and and that level of depth
maybe we're not all doing doing that but
i do think
and fabi maybe
maybe you can help me here but i do
think there's a process where a lot of
times when people are going over their
games in rapid fashion or they're trying
to memorize their opening repertoire you
can get a bit robotic and actually two
bad things can happen there one
you don't actually understand as you
said the keracon why the bishop should
be on f5 versus d7 in advance or g4 like
are you actually taking the time to
process the y not just at the current
position but in the middle games that
occurred there's a reason the bishop on
f5 is consistently misplaced because of
xyz right and i think that committing
that to memory
is much more powerful for your chest
than memorizing that on move 13 the
bishop should go to d7 versus f5 that's
the first thing i'd say and the second
thing i'm going to ask you this fabian
i'm asking a question for myself
is i've actually found that it can be
counterproductive to do too much of that
before a tournament because it puts your
brain in a space that is maybe not the
most powerful for critical thinking
which is basically you're analyzing a
position to the point that you're
willing to play it it doesn't mean
you're actually ready to play it right
and if you do too much openings where
all you're doing is memorizing where the
piece goes and not why the piece goes
there it can be doing harmful things for
your game jama bowie in addition to the
fact that you're not actually
remembering your lines as effectively as
you'd like to so bobby i know i just
added them more to that question but i
think this is a really important
question a lot of people struggle with
this so more context please can you
based on some of the things i said
yeah no i think that um
we have to be careful not to also harm
our chest with all the technology
because
uh it's very easy to
uh to get into that purely analytical
space
where you know you're doing good
analysis and you're uh
you know you're you create a file and
it's very presentable and and everything
is correct and all that but that doesn't
help you at the board when you get there
because that's when you have to think on
your own
um so one of the other helpful things
that i do for myself
is i like to go through
um the high level games in an opening
variation or a position
which were played in the past even way
in the past um
and you can look at them with a computer
you can look at them on your own and try
to think about them but um those games
are the most valuable because they show
how
people were thinking about the position
they show the the pitfalls that people
go into
um you know the typical mistakes the
let's say the directions where um
where a human might look to first and
and i think um top players use that a
lot which is
they have an idea
and very often you have an idea which is
dangerous but it's not
you know objectively leading to an
advantage and then you want to test it
against another person because you want
to see
um
what their intuition what their first
instinct is and you can't get that when
you analyze it because
um
you know your your
feeling of the position is colored by
the knowledge that the computer gave you
right that this position is a bit better
for white this is
winning for black
um
so
very often
that task of you know
what's what's the human instinct here is
given to another player so you you play
a training game against someone in this
position you say this is my idea
and now it's on you to figure out
what to do over the board and that gives
you a feeling for how a human approaches
a position
yeah uh so they're they're
although i i mean
i'll be the first to say like this
technology is
is incredibly helpful and it's it's led
to the development of
players becoming stronger younger and
the next generation and the generation
after that will will be stronger than
the previous that's i think undoubtedly
true
and
most of it is due to our knowledge and
the technology we have that allows us to
learn so much so quickly
um but you have to use it wisely
you have to make sure that you know
you're still thinking about the position
and you're not letting the computer do
the thinking for you
um so you use it as a tool rather than
you know
it's just taking control of everything
and you're just there to
uh you know to press buttons and to
create neat files
um that's that's a problem that's
it's i think anyone who seriously
analyzes openings uh will will fall into
that including players at the very top
and i know
um
that magnus um tries to
to avoid that as best he can by
uh by
trying to avoid the computer as much as
he can of course you can't avoid it
completely it's
super
helpful and important to use um but
trying to make sure that it doesn't
stifle his play you know it doesn't get
in the way of his
um
of you know his understanding of the
position
good stuff yeah we we used to say like
don't just press spacebar right spacebar
next best move or whatever and uh with
great power comes great responsibility
don't overuse the computers um
i i will double down on what bobby said
too jumbo and then we're moving on from
this training games so important right
just set up the training position from
move 13 move 15 move 20 going to be much
more effective probably to your
understanding of the position a lot of
people spend too much time doing other
things i think i think training games
are really powerful way to get better in
this in this way so all right let's move
on um
i got kp infinite next because he's on
my on my pinned list next i can move him
up that's really cool that i can do that
i
have like three separate questions that
i've been cycling through before this
moment so because everybody's been
asking different ones but i think i'll
just stick with the original one firstly
fabi great to meet you i first learned
about you with uh you know around the
same time that i you know got back into
things kind of full-time right uh so
around your time that you got in the
world chess championship
so this question is actually about uh
opening preparation
and
it's fair to say that you've got a
reputation
as
being somebody who is
just you come you come booked up you're
ready to go um there have been profiles
that characterize you almost like
botvinnik
who was
somebody who produced absolute dossiers
on people
but
my question kind of takes the form of
when is what is the difference where is
the difference between being
prepared
and playing chess
so i mean and and to kind of buttress
this question so
you returned to the board in the
candidates 2020 and the first thing you
did was you just
took mbl apart because you had spent so
much time uh working over his night off
prep that's a fair assessment right
yeah yeah that's that's fair for that
game sure so then and then when uh you
returned to i think it was the fide
grand uh swiss where you had a game
against maxim chigayev
you
just again went full automatic and
almost
it almost seemed like you're taking him
into the same exact
line in preparation and ideas
so
you know
what where where do you think the meta
is going as far as
you know we're no longer starting the
game on move one we're starting the game
on move 14 we're starting the game on
move 20.
right like we're out of book
like now
as opposed to all the way down the line
and how does that
how do we
as you know aspiring players
sort of keep ourselves
from falling into the trap of being over
prepared when we should just be trying
to figure out you know
don't blender a piece
yeah no i think that's that's a great
question um and it goes back also to the
the previous question in some ways
um
which is
that yeah preparation is uh is important
at certain levels it's super important
and we know that you know players who
play the world championship like we saw
last world championship they come with a
ton of ideas in the opening because they
want to be the one to get the first
surprise in and they're just trying to
increase their edge it's like they're
both super strong players
um they're capable of winning good
positions they're capable of losing bad
positions
but
they just want to to get that slide out
edge on their opponent because they know
that they're super close in level
um
that isn't going to
bring the same dividends to the vast
majority of players because
um
for them it's a it's very small nuances
they're trying to improve on and for
most people um games will come down to
to serious mistakes that happen in the
middle game or in the end game and they
might not necessarily be blunders they
um
it could be of course that you know
if you hang a piece it doesn't matter
how many good moves you made in the in
the opening or in the entire game
um because one mistake can can entirely
spoil it um but it could also be
positional mistakes not understanding
the position getting tired at the end of
the game
um
mistakes you know well into the end game
so there's there's a lot of um
[Music]
a lot of places to improve before you
want to focus on the opening aspect it's
just that
um
for for top players
they've already worked on most of those
aspects and
um and now they feel like their best
chance of
you know improvement and keeping up with
other people is on investing in
and opening work
and
uh the other thing is that if if you
want to completely avoid opening
preparation
um
there are there are ways to do that i
think at pretty much every level
um
one like one of the
uh
let's say revolutions in chess recently
has been that um you don't just have to
play main lines and there aren't just
a few things that are that are playable
or good openings um
it used to be that you know
people were principled they thought
you know with white you should play e4
and go for all the main lines and try to
uh and try to beat your opponent opening
and
i know just from speaking to players who
were
at their peak in the 90s
or earlier than that that they basically
felt like
you know your opponent plays e4 and
there's almost nowhere to run to with
black
um
[Music]
and things have changed massively like
computers just taught us that
um pretty much anything is playable in
the opening you can
uh you can play e4 and that's the
legitimate way and all the main lines or
you can play knight of three and b3 and
that's just as legitimate and approach
um
and that's just a stylistic difference
if you want to go for direct lines and
try to put pressure on your opponent try
to um
[Music]
let's say take advantage of
his lack of knowledge or her lack of
knowledge potentially in in the openings
and try to get as big of an advantage as
possible you can do that that's one
approach
or if you want to play more of a typical
system like the london like
you know d493b3 d493 g3
uh you can do that too and
it's just a different approach
um so the best advice i can give is
just to know your um
whatever system or opening you fight to
know as well
rather than
um to think like you know
everyone's playing the berlin or the
marshall so that's the right opening to
play
um
i don't think that's the case anymore i
think you can play the marshall
successfully or the berlin successfully
or the time auto successfully all these
openings are inherently playable not
just from
um
[Music]
a subjective point of view like you know
i know well and my opponent doesn't
doesn't know it as well and and i'll
have a leg up on him that's important
but also from an objective point of view
we found out that a lot of things which
were previously considered dubious or
unplayable or actually fully legitimate
openings um
so chess has actually been enriched a
lot in in how computers um
computers taught us that
you can you can approach the game
from the opening to the middle game in
in a huge variety of ways it's not like
it's not like people used to think that
you know there's a certain few openings
that are good and you should play those
now it's
people realize that you can basically
play anything and you can look at the
tournament going on now to feed a grand
prix and see it every every game has a
different opening one game is a french
like um today buck crowe played the
french against nakamura and got a good
position out of the opening
there's you know catalans there's
it's i think it's a testament to the
richness of chess that
um people can approach the game in in
in any way and it and it works out fine
for sure it's kind of like uh everything
everything's playable until
it's until you don't know how to play it
yeah if you don't know how to play
something whether it's a great opening
um or even like you know
there are still of course dubious
openings
but if you don't know how to play
against them they're still going to be
super tough to face it's
um
i know that from personal experience you
know you
you play against a guy who's playing the
awaken
and you think well
i mean we kind of know that this is not
the best opening in the world
um but that doesn't mean it's easy at
all and you know every
if you look at magnus he's played
dubious openings uh with success because
uh he he tries to learn something about
them tries to
um you know find out where people tend
to make mistakes and
and it's
a subjectively playable approach as well
yep
it's funny i think i think that um a lot
of the conversation about openings in
some ways are dominated below
below certain levels partly because i
always say it's it's the thing that
people feel they're most in control of
fixing
and it's the easiest thing to jump to
from one to the other when the reality
is even at the highest levels in the
world chess championship yonder pontiff
she did not lose the match to magnus
because of the opening right and and at
the highest levels of chess everywhere
blunders are made because of other
things and i think generally people
don't want to put in the time to do
hours of end game study or or or really
solving puzzles and that's coming from
the guy who's guilty of doing everything
he can to gamify the chess experience
people love puzzles because we've made
them fun and they love that they're 2
300 even though they're
you know maybe 14 or 1500 in chess right
so there's a part of that that we invest
in to try to keep people in chess but
the bottom line is like real improvement
doesn't necessarily come from doing
what's easy and it's easy to switch the
opening and like learn new moves right
and and i think that that's a really
hard thing to remember but true so
anyway
really great conversation guys i'm gonna
move on to reuben i've been told by trim
that he's next
reuben you're up dude let me let me pin
your video so everyone can see you
um let's see there you are all right and
go for it man
all right um first of all thanks for the
opportunity
so i was wondering um how do you deal
with pressure because i myself got
pretty nervous before competition match
and i couldn't imagine how it might feel
when playing the candidates or even for
a world championship
yeah that's that's that's a very
important thing um pressure stress
it affects everyone um
it's just a
a totally human
side to chest that everyone is dealing
with this and people
uh react to it better uh than others
some people react to it better than
others um
[Music]
those are inherent traits that you can't
really
you can't entirely change but you can
work on
um i think it is helpful to realize that
um if you're under pressure it's a very
high chance that your opponent is also
under pressure
um it's not
like we
chess is in some ways an individual game
that we're all on our own at the board
uh but we also have to think about it
not just from a purely individual
individual point of view but also that
our opponents are dealing with all the
same things
um
they also don't want to lose and they
are afraid of losing and they're worried
about uh
you know what's going to happen if
they'll get
surprised in the opening if they'll
blunder all these things
um
so i i think that's helpful to realize
that it's not just something that you
struggle with it's something that
everyone
from the top level down
uh including your all your opponents
will also struggle with
um
in terms of like
you know
let's say purely
um
concrete ways of dealing with it i think
that
um
i think that
like let's say you go to a sports
psychologist and they might
give you some methods some
uh some breathing exercises things like
that that might help deal with stress
and pressure
um
because it is
it is something that's in your head it's
um
and it's something that that can be
released you know there are there are
ways physical ways of dealing with
um
[Music]
of dealing with it so i i like took some
sessions with a sports psychologist a
few years ago
sorry um i forgot where i was at uh you
were talking about you actually met with
a sports psychologist a few years ago
um
yeah yeah and and we went through
breathing exercises and and
dealing with these with these issues um
it's also something that comes with
experience
um
and also comes
partly with let's say
we naturally become more nervous
or stressed when we're dealing with a
new situation
um that's just a normal thing i think
that's not just in chess but you know if
it's your first time speaking in public
or
you know first time
running a marathon not that i've ever
run a marathon but
uh it's it's going to be more
nerve-wracking the first time so the
more games you play the more you deal
with um let's say important tournament
games important in tournament situations
where you're potentially playing for
some big money or
um playing for let's say your
uh you know your final norm or you're
going to get the
master title with this game whatever
your goal is um the first time will
always be the most
uh nervous and nerve-wracking and with
time and experience you will
be just naturally better adjusted to
deal with these things so that's
something that um
i think just as humans we we adjust to
um through trial and error so
yeah practice will will also help with
that um
but it's yeah it's something that
everyone has to has to deal with it's
not just
um
i know it it
definitely feels very personal at the
time that you're stressed um
and under a lot of pressure but it's
something that that everyone is dealing
with
so is that like the equivalent of like
if you're on the stage just picture
everybody naked everybody else is more
embarrassed than you so that makes you
feel better that's kind of the advice
i i've never um yeah i've never tried
that one that's how i that's how i get
through my shows i just picture that
everyone watching me is naked and then
it makes me feel a lot better just just
kidding moving on um all right
uh max you're up buddy next question
we
i heard many times that chess is 99
percent tactics
and that's
uh rather obvious and when you
recognize the pattern
the tactical pattern you um
when you know it you will recognize it
uh immediately when you see it on the
board but the uh another
problem is uh
recognizing it many moves ahead and this
question comes to me when you
were talking about your game with bono
mario
and um
i am wondering and
am i assuming right that
the position after you calculated many
many moves uh ahead may be right
until the the checkmate
was the position that the board
before your eyes was as clear as
the position
in front of you on the chessboard
am i
thinking
correctly
oh so so from what i understand this is
um a question of visualization
um definitely yeah
yeah so so visualization is
probably the most important thing in
chess because i think that's where
mistakes and blunders
if we strip them down to the bare
essence of them that's where they come
from which is that
we're not seeing the board correctly
because although when we see it in front
of us
we see it
perfectly correctly then we have to
calculate in advance and the farther the
more different the position gets from
the position in the board
the fog area gets in our head um and
that's true for everyone although of
course
um the best players will visualize the
best
and uh people who struggle with this
visualization will um will make mistakes
in their calculation in their
you know scene tactics or even in
their evaluation evaluation of something
because all of it is tied together you
know you can
um you can mis-evaluate a position
because it doesn't it just doesn't look
clear in your head
and um and it's difficult for me to like
quantify what
what counts as clarity like when you're
looking at a position and
you kind of you know where the pieces
are
some people let's say see a visual
representation of a board
some people
see something else i i don't know
exactly what uh
what everyone sees in their head you
know when when they're looking at a
position
that's different than the board in front
of them
yeah this is this is super important for
tactics and for calculation and this is
where
um
where mistakes come from
and and the way to train that i would
say is um is through practice yeah if
you
if you're doing calculation exercises
constantly that trains you
even though
you may never get that that exact
position over the board let's say you're
you know you're sitting down to try to
solve a benko study um
just to give one example
um
that trains your calculation in a way
which
you might not even realize it but that
but it will help you
um it'll help you visualize and
calculate in your games
um and also when it comes to calculation
i think a lot of it is discipline
a lot of it is
not stopping too early things like that
which there are mistakes that you can
you can solve
it just takes a great deal of discipline
um
but yeah it's
and i can tell you that uh
the mistakes that i've made the very
serious ones they've
uh very often come from just not seeing
the board correctly sometimes they
even the board in front of you you don't
see correctly like i mean i just
blundered my rook in my last tournament
um because i didn't see that knight can
move backwards
we weren't gonna talk about that but
since you brought it up i mean rook b6
bro like you know yeah
um
but i think also with mistakes like that
it's
uh they don't exist in a vacuum like you
they're an accumulation of
a lot of factors and in the case of that
game
um it was a somewhat it was a pretty
lousy game from both of us it was a bit
out of control and once you lose control
um
you know
your chest ability can start to fall
apart
uh
it's
like one once you no longer feel like
you're in control
once you feel like you know i've missed
half the things in this game and i've
mis-evaluated positions and i've missed
wins and i've
been losing at some point all that is
stuck in your head somehow and it leads
to mistakes later on the road it's it's
very difficult to on the spot keep
readjusting to to chaotic situations
that's why
uh
the best players try to keep
things under control so that
so that they don't have to deal with all
the wild emotions and
all the stress and tension and nervous
energy that you expend
um when when you lose control of the
game
uh
so yeah
you know when we talk about blunders
sometimes we think how can how can a
player you know miss that because
it's just so simple but um but all this
is the accumulation of what happens
throughout a game
uh psychologically emotionally and
in terms of your energy reserves all
these things are are things that you
have to factor in uh from the start of
the game you know if
if you don't feel like you are
you know ready to
uh to play a super complex
and
you know wild game
you don't you feel like you won't have
the energy for that type of game then
uh then you shouldn't go for that and
you should try to control the situation
from the start uh if you feel like you
know i have all the energy in the world
today then then maybe you can go for it
and try to throw caution to the wind
um but yeah i think the important thing
is that
yeah mistakes they um
yeah they don't happen on their own
they're usually
it's
maybe in some ways detective work you
know you have to look through
all the game and all the
calculations and all the emotions you
were feeling and
backtrack to why
it led to that mistake
fascinating stuff and that you know all
samex there are a lot of different
exercises and things that have been
suggested over the years as far as how
to build uh visualization muscles so i'm
going to give you some advice on that if
you send me a message later all kinds of
different russian chess school tricks
and yeah
your video series on that yet so yeah
yeah and the video series taps in this
one but no it's it's a it's it's super
important i think like fabiano said i
think arguably it's the most important
thing right it's easy to see it when
it's right in front of you but seven
moves down the road right so anyway
definitely good stuff um all right we
got two more people up here we're gonna
go to shasta goat and then crypto
sorry um crypto flop yeah crypto flop
you're you're you're gonna be last there
so
shaas um go for it ma'am
thanks danny um hi fabi i would like to
ask um
actually i would like to preface my
question with a little story
i played chess for about uh one year and
then i joined a under 1800 tournament
it was a
a weekend tournament so six rounds and
nine thirty
i managed to go four out of six and i'm
pretty happy with the result but i'm not
happy at all with the chess i played
and also not with uh studying i did
before the tournaments game
so i spent about one month studying
every single neighbor's line i could
find accessible
i studied uh the amateurs mind by jeremy
zillman the entire book i just wrote it
all out i memorized everything with it
but
then when i actually sat down at the
board and started playing for you know
my first time over the board it was i
didn't get
a neither for a single time i didn't get
to play my prep at all
and all the knowledge just flew out the
window
so
what what happens why why do you just
sit down at the board and forget
everything and just start looking at
moves and
start intuitively thinking instead of
actually recalling what you studied yeah
no that's um
that's yeah that's a great question um
because
i i can think of things that happened in
in my career which were similar which is
you know you you prepare something
before tournament and opening um that
fascinates you
and then you don't get a chance to play
it and it feels like you wasted your
time but i actually don't think that you
wasted your time at all because
um the knowledge that you got from
studying the night or and going through
all those courses and looking at all the
games you looked at
um that's knowledge that doesn't go away
and it might not happen in the next
tournament that you get those night or
positions and
use that the knowledge and the
variations that you learned
but at some point
in your tournament career or you know in
your chess plane you'll get those
positions and you'll use that knowledge
um
so whatever work you do you might not
see the immediate benefits of it but
it's still useful um so i i would say
don't be discouraged by
by that experience um
because uh because at some point that
work that you did will
uh will help you and it's it's just
generally you should think of it more as
you're learning about chats not that uh
there's a time limit for you know i have
to use this knowledge but you're
continuing to learn about chess you're
getting better uh you're improving with
uh with all the work that you do and all
the games that you look at
and
um and it doesn't matter if it you know
brings dividends in in the next
tournament because at some point it will
um sometimes you have to be
very patient to use the
stuff that you do but at some point it
will
it'll pay off um so yeah i would say you
know don't don't change
uh don't change that continue studying
what you
find interesting and um
and you will at some point be able to
use it
and um
and yeah that's something also i had to
kind of learn with experience because it
is disappointing
um and sometimes it even happens in
uh
you know in a
more direct way like let's say you find
an idea an opening that you want to use
and you think nobody knows it and you
don't get a chance to play then six
months later someone plays it
and now everyone knows it and you feel
like you just you wasted all your time
um but now i don't think of it as
wasting time it's just
um you know you work on chests to to
improve yourself and if
uh
you know bad luck happens and someone
uses that idea that you found first
then um oh yeah that's just that's just
how it happens sometimes um but
it's still good to to do that work it
teaches you about the game
um
and all you should really be trying to
focus on is
uh increasing your knowledge and
um
and improving your play
um and also it sounds like you had a
good tournament anyway so
so maybe that chess work that you did
even though it didn't directly
um
show up
show its benefit maybe there was still
something there that you got your mind
and chess and
um and you were you were primed to play
in some way and that helped out anyway
good good stuff and i'll even say too
that
sometimes the not everyone has problems
with others stealing their novelties
fabiano like you do um at the high
levels but you know i've had many times
too where like like you said you're
working on something focus on
appreciating the labor of the love right
you learn to love the process and when
you do that i've had times where like i
prepared something specifically for
something and then literally eight
months later had a chance to use it
right sometimes it just doesn't always
happen in the way you think it's going
to and so there definitely is a lot of
truth to that right it's what is this
saying about chess like anyone can learn
it but like nobody can master it or
whatever like you're going to be doing
that forever you know and uh anyway good
pep talk fabi all right um
our last question is going to come to us
from crypto flop
crypto flop you have the floor i don't
think we have a webcam for you um
but uh go ahead and uh give us your
question
i see the question can i ask my question
in chat so the answer is yes go ahead
and type your question in chat i don't
see the question
i can i can i can read it out it is so
how does one maintain motivation because
sometimes i'll play really badly in
rapid games where i'm like really uh
missing everything and says all right
screw this and play 30 straight games of
hyper bullet and not touch chess for a
week so like how do i deal with that
vodka maintains motivation with a lot of
clash royale
in the in the background
that's a good question because it's um
it's something that i struggle with too
that my motivation rises and dips
and i don't even necessarily know why
um
i i think that's a purely personal thing
you know why why you might be motivated
at times it might be
uh due to your chest results um
sometimes you know you you have some bad
results and you want to put chest out
for a while um and i would say if that's
the case then uh then you should
probably do that it's it's better to
um
to take a break
uh from playing or from studying rather
than burn yourself out
and maybe if you take a break it will
help you
um
when you come back into studying chess
or playing a tournament or playing
online help you um
find some renewed motivation uh so
um but yeah that's something that i
personally struggle with so if i knew
how to turn motivation on all the time i
would
i would use that for myself uh so i
don't have like um
like let's say a trick for that
it's just something that comes and goes
and
uh and you also have to find what
what works for you when you're
um
you know when you're unmotivated or even
when you're tilting right you know we
all have those moments when
uh we lose a bunch of games or we play a
bunch of bad games and
uh and we start to tilt and
you know the instinct is just to keep on
playing but sometimes it's good to put
it down for a bit take a break and
um
you know re-focus your head a bit
and uh
and then maybe you'll come back stronger
from that
good advice good advice for everyone um
i think that's it trim you can confirm i
think we've had everyone
an opportunity
to have questions in for those who were
you have been all great
a part of this experience so
anyway well fabi i uh i think this this
has been this has been awesome and
hopefully hopefully i speak for everyone
that this was this was pretty cool and
uh good good practical advice
um
i guess i guess this is where we find a
way to sign off and just say thank you
everybody for being here um any last
awkward awkward things to say before we
go bobby
no thanks thanks guys for coming and
listening um
to this uh i hope everyone enjoyed it
had a good experience
yeah for sure and not not so awkward but
uh but true and i think this was awesome
man and uh
all right well uh thank you everybody
we're gonna we're gonna maybe be seeing
this
in some different uh some different
formats hit the web so you're looking
for a little recap in fact it'll be a
good refresher for anyone who wants to
review the things that fabiano said that
we're legendary um quick thing sorry
danny uh small request fabi can you can
you say it can you say the line for us
which line
i think they they all want you to say
you know that's the stupidest you know
what
i don't know i think that's that's one
and done we're not doing that
okay good i like that keep it even keep
it tight um
all right man um
the um
that was funny kp but all right you'll
just have to watch the video just have
to watch the video um all right guys
thank you so much these were amazing
questions and really really awesome
insights we could probably talk chess
psychology for hours but we'll wrap it
up there and so um again just going to
say
way to go
rock on chess.com chess community thanks
for being here and um
bobby we'll uh we'll let you go so i'm
going to go ahead and bring our bring
our classroom to a close here
i think all i have to do is close out
and uh and good stuff follow up with
trim everybody um our community leaders
if you if you have any other questions
or need any other um
need any other pieces of info given so
all right i'm gonna wrap it up there
thank everybody and thanks to the team
who helped make uh make this possible
all right
bye everybody
bye guys
[Music]
you